what up reject nation how's your day
going aaron alexander is back with us
today because we covered umbrella
academy season two together right here
on the channel you guys can go watch
those reactions if you haven't seen them
because right now we got ourselves
umbrella academy season 3 trailer
finally another show to add on to the
big list of june 2022 so
guys if you want to show your support to
us over at our patreon page by becoming
a super sexy reject that would mean so
much we'll have the full length watch
along where you sync up with the time
code for umbrella academy over there and
we cover a whole bunch of shows but many
of them exclusive reaction highlights
over there especially because we're
going to be uh getting some extra
editing help to help us keep up and so
that those patreon funds really help go
to there and uh if you can't do that you
know leave a like and a comment
that's just as good so do that mean a
lot and subscribe and click that
notification bell as well you can follow
this guy you're gonna instagram again
no don't follow him just just say nice
things follow me in the streets let's
let's let's watch these people follow
her and stalk
him this isn't your home
what are you talking about this is the
umbrella academy
this is the sparrow cabin
what
[ __ ]
good shot
our little paradox brought forth the
freaking cougar blitz what the hell is
cougar blitz essentials
we're screwed
just like an old man
everybody else could see ben right yeah
and he's a complete [ __ ]
the next person to say [ __ ] is
getting a punch to the throat [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ]
we caused a paradox and that paradox is
swallowing
oh no maybe five days before the rest of
existence is blitzed
classic blobs and cubes and birds and
[ __ ]
your team is good but i don't think
you're better than me
i entered the world twice
and you you're
but those babies still existed here so
if you ever see your other selves kill
them sleep with them avoid them
come on
climb luther mountain
[Music]
[Applause]
what are you their mascot
more like their ringer it's a ballroom
what
i'm excited
i'm looking for you
oh
spoiler alert
hey
oh i'm excited pogo lives pogo pogo live
the return of biker gang pogo
[Laughter]
i was there the whole time you just
couldn't see him yeah we're in like this
age of comic book alternate timeline
multi-verses everywhere again like we've
had multiverse madness and everything
marvel's been doing everything
everywhere all at once everywhere that's
the new hot craze flashpoint film coming
and now this so it's like we gotta get
rid of the sparrow academy and then keep
pogo alive though right keep pogo alive
especially living okay so we just
watched this trailer back on our own
this trailer moves by such a whiplash
pace i didn't realize that you see lila
several times throughout this trailer
she's like like a flash she's blonde now
which is something new i thought that
was very cool i thought that she didn't
go back with them at the end is this a
different lila i would imagine it's the
same lila because they're working
together but yeah she has the briefcases
and so you time travel all right yeah
she's gonna go dimension option or
whatever but it's interesting seeing
that she's back with them and because
especially she like left at the end of
the last season kind of leaving it up in
the air as to what her status would be
with the team it's really cool to see
that they're keeping the tone of the
show the same as the last one it seems
like a whip a whiplash of a ride you
know back to the five-day format before
the
i apocalypse it even with the classics
baby well what's the cause of it this
time uh something about a paradox like
they could be
because they can't it's not time this
time it's a paradoxes time it's not
vanya who's now victor apparently
there's an article that came out like a
month ago bonnie is becoming victor in
the show that's very awesome i look i'm
happy that elliot page is going to be
able to be someone that is who they feel
that they are which is like hey you know
more more power to them yeah yeah amen
brother
i think it's one of the cool parts of
the that shot with victor and and lila
because remember that big reveal in last
season when when lila like shoots up and
scared like what
she has the same powers you know
and she was just an enemy just so to see
her working side by side it's cool more
importantly diego's got a haircut i
thought that hair in season two was
actually pretty cool but apparently a
lot of people thought it was a little
silly they changed it to satisfy the
fans yeah you're always always giving in
to fan outrage
cowards
but the sparrow academy i wonder if they
will have some type of team up at the
end i haven't read the comics so i don't
know but i wonder if only in the
beginning the sparrow academy and
umbrella academy are not going to be
getting along that's part of the the fun
of the crossover you know how like those
you know like avengers did it and stuff
where oh no they're butting heads at
first and they're fighting with each
other so you get to watch their powers
go toe-to-toe and then you see them team
up with each other in the end to help
save the world or some of their main
villainous yeah i feel like you know the
show like umbrella academy i think that
would be something that you would see
within other shows and like that'd be
really cool i would like to see them
team up i think the show has a habit of
subverting expectations with what you
suspect to be the norm with superhero
content or comic book content yeah i
think that would be really cool i would
love to see who they are explore like
the dynamics between the umbrella
academy and the spyro academy what i
want to know is what their relationship
is with one this new pogo because that's
very cool to see that pogo pogo is
returned
he does tattoos reinvented every season
i hope he has like a cockney accent this
time
yeah i would also like to see like what
the new relationship was with this new
hargraves and what the new hargraves is
like within this world and they revealed
that hargreaves was an alien last season
they did that yeah yeah we have to
unpack that definitely yeah that's going
to be something that's
hopefully has its own lore and its own
storyline within the show we got to see
if allison cares about her kid this
season right yeah
and also what i really want to know is
who are this universe's versions of the
characters that we know do they know
each other do they utilize their powers
in the same ways as our characters now i
think it's neat with ben how you know
ben was only with klaus for the first
couple seasons now that ben's back he's
antagonistic yeah that's a that's an
interesting way to like shake it all up
i feel like they're landing more in a
horror this season too yeah cause you
saw some ghosts in there and then like
so there's some new sort of mcguffin
thing that we have with the crows too
the crows the crow girl we have like a
blob kind of dude with his face and he
is in the suit
we know we're talking about you know
we're talking about what we're talking
about i'm excited to check out and
unpack it looks just as exciting as the
last two seasons looks like it's up in
the ante i think that with umbrella
academy the trailers are always like so
cool and so exciting but what makes this
show awesome is they it's mainly just a
really strong character-driven show but
it maintains that excitement throughout
it's very unique you know it's it's
difficult to stand out in the superhero
landscape of tv umbrella academy
definitely makes its mark all right
funny and funny too yeah a great needle
drops throughout i think the way they
infuse their needle drops which always
makes for great youtube monetization
but the way they they utilize their
needle drops is uh some of the absolute
best too i believe they actually the
writers
write their scenes
around it like they plan it preemptively
unlike most shows that do it in post
they they have it in mind already that's
where they write it so i think that's
why they work so well all right guys
well thank you so much for being here
what excited you most about the umbrella
academy season three trailer poker hey
let's see
pandemic jones now you might think that
having a name like pandemic jones would
mean you're a threat to this world
and you know what he's not he's actually
one of the nicest people
we've ever met one time
i'll never forget this i once fell down
a flight of stairs and you know what
pandemic did because my ankle was broken
he peed on my ankle to heal it
yeah and i was like what the hell are
you doing and he's like your ankles hurt
he thought that if your ankles hurt that
you have to pee on it like it's not a
jellyfish thing you freaking idiot and
then i smacked him in the face
and you know what he said to me after i
smacked him in the face while he was
still urinating
he said
thank you for teaching me a lesson greg
and i said
this is not the way you want to learn
lessons
in life pj and now
she is a professor
at the los angeles valley community
college so pj what we've learned today
is we have shouted you out so many times
that i am pulling from the bottom of the
barrel
of what we can say
you're a great guy and you're far
smarter than me
that story is fake so you know that i
was just joking when i said the whole
idea right
[Music]